a hard-line cleric sweeps to victory in
iran's
presidential election a partial official
result gives ibrahim raising nearly
two-thirds of the vote
the only moderate candidate has already
conceded
rice is a harsh critic of the west he's
been sanctioned for
alleged human rights abuses including
overseeing the executions of thousands
of political prisoners
election turnout was low many voters
were deterred by years of authoritarian
rule
and the flatlining economy
now let's cross straight to afp
correspondent amir havasi
in tehran it's good to have you on the
program
after a vote that saw a low turnout it's
looking
like ibrahim ricey is set to win what do
people make of that
uh well it depends on who you ask right
now at this time
last night was uh quite a situation with
people
still expecting the moderate candidate
and matty to
have a comeback or have a presence and
at the same time a lot of people being
surprised by the
votes rise he was getting
the people right now if we can have like
a
major issue that everyone would have
it's the economy
and it's widely expected for ic to be
able or at least
have the mandate or the possibility to
fix it
because as we know the negotiations in
vienna have
uh somehow stalled and there's been talk
that they would prefer to continue them
or at least reach a conclusion
for uh after iran's presidential
election
and ibrahimovic as a conservative or
ultra conservative we can say president
will have
a matching parliament and it would be
a good mix of forces to be able to push
a mandate
so it's possible for iran's economy to
be able to be
improved after that and for him to be
able to
fulfill on that economic promise the
economy is a major one there
but even just looking at this process of
the election itself
we saw a contest where many candidates
were barred from
standing what does this tell us about
where iran is heading
uh well that would be very difficult to
tell
at this point right now the thing we do
know
is that the guardian council which
that's the candidates and chooses who
can run
has set up a homogeneous number of
people
and has basically said basically did set
up risi
for victory because uh hemati compared
to
adidas the ex parliament speaker and
current advisor to the
supreme leader was not as favorable as a
candidate
and going forward
i would believe that in a sense is the
at least the end of uh disillusionment
with the reformists front with the
belief in the possibility of reformism
at this point and with this
forces or with the way they have been
going forward with their alliance with
uh president hassan rouhani
and uh with the people who have been
their flag bearers for
the public so in a sense this would
at least be the rise of conservatives
again
after quite some time after msnbc was in
power
that at least should be telling us some
things right
now you've talked about the economy
we've talked about this
electoral process but briefly what as a
whole
do iranians want to see from their
president
uh primarily yes it is the economy the
very simple things
to not see the value of real a slide
every
few weeks to not to be able to go to the
supermarket
and not see the prices and suddenly uh
jumping 50 to be able to count on the
wage you have
to buy a home down the road uh the very
simple things right now and that
is part of the uh the reason for the
apathy and the disillusionment of the
public
with the vote uh i don't think we're
going to see very
very major uh change regarding the
things we have on our plate right now
regarding foreign policy
but there are at least
right now some uh concerning signs at
least
about uh internet freedom
and uh civil society because mr iac
has uh for instance said during the beta
and before the debates
right a tier-based internet system might
be in the works
right so that will be a major uh
change compared to the period of mr
rouhani
okay so all of those combined will give
us a picture
that the economy might be improved but
at the same time the
civil society's reach might be limited
and
foreign policy as is right now the
system mandate would go on as it is
right
okay amir havasi sorry that's all the
time we have right now
but thank you for bringing us up to
speed from tehran that's afp
correspondent amir havasi
you